-Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy Award-winning singer
and songwriter
whose new album, "Chemistry,"
is available now.
You also know her as the host
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
which airs weekdays.
Check your local listings
for times.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend and now neighbor
Kelly Clarkson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Oh, my God, I love your show.
Do you know that you all
look like Smurfs
on the TV back there?
Like, everything is blue.
-Everything is blue?
-You're all blue in the TV --
-In the dressing room --
-No, right before
you enter the stage.
-I see. Yeah.
-I was like, "Oh."
-I've never seen myself on that,
'cause when I'm back there,
I'm not on the screen.
-Yeah, it would be tough.
-I've tried
to run back and forth.
How are you?
-While inebriated.
-You are new to the building.
This is your first week
of shows here.
Today was your first episode.
-You have been to my show.
-I was on your first episode.
What an honor.
-What an honor it was
to have you.
You know I love you,
so it was an honor to have you.
-How do you like it so far,
being in 30 Rock?
-I love it. I didn't really
realize the underground vibe.
Like, there's
so many restaurants.
There's, like, a whole world.
like, underneath.
Like, I didn't know.
-Wait until Christmas.
There's a giant tree outside
that's going to blow your mind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I knew that one.
-And you've never
lived here before.
This is your first time
living here.
-It's my first time living here.
And I love it.
-I think this is
the perfect time of year
to move to New York City.
-I agree. Like, especially
for me personally, like,
it helped that my kids
were like 100% into it.
-Oh, that's good.
-Yeah, yeah.
So it's helpful --
When they're happy, I'm happy.
-Yeah. Right.
-Yeah.
-And how do they like it so far?
-They love it.
-Are they excited
for their first Halloween
in New York City?
-They are.
But actually, the thing
they just got excited about --
They've been to a show before
but not since we've lived here.
And it was a long time ago.
So they saw "Lion King"
the other night.
And then I saw "Lion King"
three times yesterday
'cause they re-enacted
the entire thing.
And they're like,
"You know what?
I'm gonna do it over.
I can do better."
And I'm like, "Oh,
we're gonna start fresh,
aren't we, like, again.
Okay."
-Like, "We're going to
go get our big puppets."
-Okay.
-My wife took our 7-year-old
to "Lion King," and he loved it.
But then they got
in a cab to go back downtown,
and he has a very early bedtime.
-Oh, so do my kids.
-Okay.
-So his thing was --
-That's so we have a life.
-Yeah. 100%.
When people are like,
"My kids go to bed at 9:30,"
I'm like, "And now why
don't you poison yourself?"
-Yeah.
I'm like, "What?"
-"How do you
make your life happy?"
-I will totally lie about
actually the time if I'm tired
and be like, "Bedtime."
Or my daughter's like,
"Are you sure?"
I'm like, "Totally sure.
Shut the blinds. It's fine."
-This summer, I'd be like,
"It's nighttime,"
and they'd pull the blinds back
and it would be like
the sun would, like, blast in.
-It's just weird.
-So when she brought
my son home from "Lion King,"
he'd never seen
Times Square at night.
And so he saw "Lion King."
But then he got home.
I'm like, "How was it?"
He's like, "You can't believe
where we live."
He's like, "You have
no idea what's happening
just on a light level
in the city."
-That was my kids, actually.
That was probably the first time
that they've been
to Times Square,
like, at nighttime, yeah.
-It's really awesome.
-It is. It's really magical.
-When your kids realize
what New York City is...
-Yeah, and it keeps you busy.
There's so many things
to do all the time.
So, yeah.
-And now you obviously
have hosted this show in L.A.,
and I imagine
you're in a new studio.
It's a little bit different,
but it must also feel like
riding a bike
to some degree now.
-Yeah, I mean, honestly,
like, from the very first --
I like talking,
if you haven't noticed.
So that part's very easy to me.
I think the difference
for this season
is I really needed
that fresh start,
like, on a personal note,
just --
Yeah, it's a rough few years,
and I just needed it.
So I don't know
that I've done this show
like this kind of happy before.
-That's wonderful to hear.
-So, yeah.
-It comes across.
-It does, yeah.
-Also, I want to give
a shout-out.
You had a very novel idea
for your first show.
I was there, and the entire
audience was doormen.
-Yes.
-New York City doormen
and doorwomen.
And what gave you that idea?
Why did you want to honor
our doormen and -women?
-Well, we're meshing
our crew now, right?
'Cause we have some from L.A.,
some from New York.
And, like, I think a lot of us,
we just got here
and we're like,
"Wow, these are, like,
essential people in your life
that you don't realize.
You see every --
like, more than your family.
And so -- And we were like,
"Yeah, let's do this."
You know, a producer
came up with the idea,
and then it was just so magical.
You don't realize, like you
were talking about on my show,
like, how your kids grow up
with these people.
Like, you're always passing.
They're so helpful.
It's like a part of your life
every day.
-It's 100%.
-Yeah.
-You had a leg up on decorating
your dressing rooms.
-Well, I'm the Wayfair lady,
as well, so...
-Yes, you got that
going for you.
-Yeah, I've got that
going for me.
No, but I did actually.
It's awesome, because anytime
we do decorate somewhere,
I'm like, "Can I?"
I always pull my discount
and I'm like, "Can I?"
'Cause I have a new collection
'cause I love Montana so much.
And I actually really love the,
like, chic kind of ranch vibe.
Like, that's my thing, so we
came up with a whole new thing.
So you might see that backstage
at my show.
-You also talked briefly
at your show beforehand
that you're into fantasy
football this year, first year.
-Oh, my God.
How did you do
this past weekend?
-Monday night decides it.
So when this airs,
I will know how it went,
but it doesn't look good.
-It was not great for me.
-But you also -- I said,
"Oh, that's so exciting.
You're doing it.
Who was your first pick?"
And you said a name that
made me think you're bad at it.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's the reason why.
Okay, now I'm into it.
Now I know the players',
like, real names.
-So on draft day,
you admit you blew it.
-But on draft day, I admit --
I didn't blow it,
because I have Walker, Seattle,
and he's really good.
Like, Walker III, what?
-But who'd you take first?
Do you even remember who?
-I do.
It was Kirk Cousins.
And here's the reason why.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
He was ranked high.
And then also, I met him
and I like him,
and I like Cousins BBQ,
and so I was like, "Cool."
-I mean, those are all
terrible reasons.
-No, I'm not kidding.
I picked Andrews from the Ravens
because I like Julie Andrews.
I picked R. Wilson
'cause Rita Wilson is awesome.
This is how I picked
my team at first.
But now I studied up
and I realized on NFL+,
you can go back and watch.
If you have the premium,
you can go back and watch games.
Now I'm studying up.
Now I know players.
I was talking to Erin backstage.
I'm ready for next season.
-Well, I think maybe next year.
I think next year
is where you start.
-No, I did kill it, like,
a couple weeks so far.
Just not this one.
-By the way, this really
is bringing home the idea
that fantasy football
is different than football
if you're basically
drafting people
because they remind you
of Julie Andrews
and you're doing
as well as I am.
-When you don't know
the people, you don't know --
I'm like, "I don't know.
They have a lot of points,
it says."
And the projections?
Whatever. They lie.
-Yeah.
-Liars.
-You know what?
We finally agree on something.
The projections?
-The projections are lying.
-Liars.
You guys, this is very exciting.
Kelly Clarkson!
Fifth season of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
airs weekdays.
Check your local listings.
Her fantastic new album,
"Chemistry," is out now.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with Erin Andrews.